hello everyone it's seven o'clock you're
watching Sky News breakfast now we knew
it wouldn't be good but the Autumn
statement signals a drop in household
income of seven percent wiping out eight
years of growth and leaves the front
pages describing the government's
economic plan as pain misery and Carnage
well the chancellor insisters package
will make the recession shallower and
shorter and Jeremy Hunt joins me in the
next few minutes later on I'll also
speak to Labor's Shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves and the deputy leader of
the liberal Democrats Daisy Cooper it's
Friday the 18th of November a collapse
in living standards higher taxes and
cuts to public spending the chancellor
is under Fire for a budget which spares
no one
foreign
and growing demand are set to wipe out
nearly all of the new NHS funding
announced by the chancellor according to
new analysis shared exclusively with Sky
News
world leaders convene an emergency
meeting after North Korea fires are
suspected intercontinental ballistic
missile capable in theory of hitting the
U.S mainland
the Biden Administration rules that
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
has immunity in a lawsuit over the
murder of journalists Jamal khashoggi
Twitter closes its offices as scores of
employees start leaving the company
following an ultimatum from new owner
Elon Musk
Poland puts on a show of force Two
fighter jets accompany the country's
football team on their way to the World
Cup in Qatar after this week's missile
strike
also ahead this morning I'm going to be
speaking to the paralympic gold
medalists undertaking a record-breaking
Journey to the South Pole
[Music]
foreign
good morning to you now Jeremy Hunt the
chancellor is facing criticism for his
Autumn statement which will push the
UK's tax burden to its highest level
since the second world war Mr Hunt
announced a package of tax Rises and
spending cuts to try to fill the black
hole in public finances now this comes
as experts warn of a record fall in
living standards across the country so
here are some of the key announcements
that he made the office for Budget
responsibility said that the size of
Britain's economy its GDP is likely to
shrink by 1.4 next year inflation is
expected to average 9.1 percent this
year with unemployment likely to go up
to nearly five percent by 2024. now
household budgets are expected to fall
by an average of 7.1 percent over the
next two years and that's the biggest
drop ever recorded
the top rate of income tax will come
down from 150 000 pounds to just over
125 000 pounds and other income tax bans
and personal allowances will be frozen
until 2028 capturing millions in higher
rates
average energy bills will be capped at
three thousand pounds from next April
that's 500 pounds higher than before and
the windfall tax on energy firms profits
will go up from 25 to 35 percent
now there's help for those most in need
the state pension means tested and
disability benefits Rise by a 10.1
percent in line with inflation and the
NHS budget will increase slightly by 3.3
billion pounds per year for the next two
years and schools will get an extra 2.3
billion pounds a year
so plenty to talk about with the
chancellor Jeremy Hunt who joins me now
at Joey hunt very good morning to you
thanks so much for talking to us here on
Sky news this morning so Britain faces
its biggest hits and living standards on
record wiping out eight years of
improvements the economy is already in
recession and now people are facing a
huge rise in the tax burden you've been
in power for 12 years it's a pretty
bleak Legacy from the conservatives
isn't it
but what we have is a very challenging
International situation uh the dropping
growth in Germany for example is even
higher than here countries all over the
world are dealing with the inflation
shock caused by the Ukraine crisis and
what we have to do as a government is to
say what is the big thing that we can do
to help families to help businesses the
most and what people are worried about
is the rise in the cost of living that
Weekly shop going up their mortgage
rates going up their energy Bills going
up and this is a plan which when you cut
through the difficult decisions that I
announced yesterday it brings inflation
right down you start to see growth going
right up and you start to see our
economy getting back onto an even Keel
and that's the most important thing as a
conservative I know sometimes you have
to take difficult decisions but if in
the end that means more stability for
families and we're protecting the NHS
and schools as you said then we know
we're doing the right thing for the long
term and that's what we do in these
kinds of situations would you say you
say that it's a challenging
International situation you're blaming
Global factors and undoubtedly the
pandemic and the war in Ukraine have had
an impact but don't the conservatives
need to take some responsibility as well
I mean a lot of what you're doing is
about undoing the mess that the mini
budget made and also taking steps to try
to convince the markets that you're
trustworthy
well we reverse those measures in the
miniature budget in three weeks so I
think we acted very quickly we've been
completely open yes there were some
mistakes but when you look at America
that's increased taxes by 800 billion
dollars you look at uh Germany and
France that are now saying they're going
to reduce their borrowing and introduce
much stricter rules you look at what
Putin is doing in Ukraine this is an
international situation coming straight
after a once in a lifetime pandemic so
these are very serious issues sorry to
interrupt Jeremy Hunt but we have the
lowest growth in the G7 why is that
well that's not true we actually have
the highest growth in the G7 this year
and if you look at the last 12 years
we've actually had the third highest
growth in the G7 despite a lot of global
turbulence now over the next two years
it is going to be challenging but I
think people want a government that is
taking difficult decisions has a plan
that will bring down inflation stop
those big rises in the the cost of
energy bills in the weekly shop and at
the same time it's taking measures to
help people get through this difficult
period the support for energy bills will
mean that the average house will have
500 pounds less to pay in their energy
bills we've increased the national
living wage which will mean an extra
sixteen hundred pounds in the pay
packets of people who work full-time and
indeed protecting the triple lot for
pensioners so we're doing absolutely
everything we can to help people whilst
tackling this this very very challenging
International situation
but you're part of the same government
that said we were going to see the
biggest tax cuts in 50 years a 45
billion pounds worth just eight weeks
ago now you're announcing huge tax Rises
and spending cuts as well worth a total
of 55 billion pounds what's the public
supposed to make of this total reversal
in Direction in just a short space of
time what does it do to the conservative
party's credibility
well we've been honest with people that
there were some mistakes made but we're
also saying there are much bigger issues
to solve than what happened in the mini
budget we've got a big challenge because
of the costs of covid the costs of the
war in Ukraine and what we announced
yesterday was a long-term plan to see us
through to the other side and I think
people want a government that is
prepared to take difficult decisions to
write the economy to protect jobs
yesterday the office for Budget
responsibility said the measures I
announced will save 70 000 jobs they'll
reduce the severity of the recession by
about a third so that is a government
that is doing everything it can to help
families get through what is a very very
challenging period
will you say help families through a
challenging period but disposable income
is going to fall by more than seven
percent over the next two years that's
the biggest fall on record we're all
going to be a lot worse off aren't we
that's what happens when you have high
inflation and that's what happens when
Putin is able to Blackmail us and
countries all over the world by forcing
a big rise in international gas prices
and that's why one of the things we
announced yesterday was a new nuclear
power plant the first state-backed
nuclear power plant for 30 years to try
and stop people like Putin being able to
do that blackmail which is so damaging
to our living standards I think it's
important Anna to recognize as a country
we've had bigger challenges before
and we've always thrived and prospered
because people have been able to or been
willing to take tough difficult
decisions when they're called for
because people know in their hearts
there are big big issues that we have to
resolve and they want a government
that's prepared to take those decisions
people will also ask how they're going
to pay their bills I mean we're facing
the worst two years of modern history
for household incomes millions are going
to be dragged into higher tax bans
Council taxes likely to go up energy
bills up again in the spring and they're
already
eye-wateringly high the resolution
Foundation says the typical annual tax
bill Will Rise by 1700 pounds how are
people going to afford it
well that's why we announced a lot of
things yesterday let me tell you some of
the things that we announced that will
help people first of all uh the cap on
energy bills at 3 000 pounds will save
the average house 500 pounds uh the
increase in the state pension by a
record 10.1 percent will increase the
average pensioners uh income by 870
pounds then you've got the increase in
the National living wage which we talked
about up to 1600 pounds then we're doing
one-off payments to people on benefits
of 900 pounds one-off payments to
pensioners of 300 pounds on our payments
to people on with disabilities to of 150
pounds and then you've got the reversal
of the Health and Social care Levy which
is again another nearly 400 pounds so
you know put those together and for the
most vulnerable people there are
thousands and thousands of pounds of
help that we're offering but we're doing
more than that we're saying what is the
long-term solution to these cost of
living pressures it's to bring down
inflation and this is a plan that sees
inflation fall markedly in the second
half of next year and that in the end is
going to be the thing that deals with
people's the root cause of people's
worries and that's what we've tried to
do today
one of the things you mentioned there
and that was honoring the triple lock
seeing pensions rise with inflation is
it fair though that wealthy retirees
should enjoy that rise in their income
when public sector workers can't
well I think the truth is first of all
pensioners have retired they don't have
the ability to work more or work longer
hours in the way that uh people of
working age do but I think it's wrong to
say that only the poorest pensioners are
feeling the squeeze at the moment I
think this is something that's affecting
everyone and I think it's right having
made that promise to pensioners in our
Manifesto that we would have this triple
lock I think this is exactly the kind of
tough time that people want it to kick
in and so that's why I think it's the
right thing to do but when a lot of
people say you are protecting pensioners
but it's workers that are really being
clobbered aren't they given the tax
Rises that are being imposed on them
does it pay to work under your plans
well we've just increased the national
living wage to 10 pounds 42 that's
nearly 10 increase and that's precisely
to make sure we do reward people for
working and support people who are on
Lower pay so I think we're very aware of
those challenges we're not pretending
that this isn't going to be a difficult
time for everyone but what we have is a
plan we're protecting the NHS and
schools as we get through a difficult
period And when we get to the other side
you can see inflation coming right down
growth going right up unemployment
coming down all the things that you know
their economic statistics but they
actually affect ordinary families up and
down the country they affect how much we
pay for the things we buy the effect the
security of our jobs and that's why our
first responsibility has to be to take
the difficult decisions that sort out
the root problems the economy is facing
the tax Rises you've announced are
astonishing as a share of GDP that
they're at their highest level since the
second world war and there are many in
your own party that are deeply
uncomfortable about that about putting
up taxes when we're in recession they
say it's not very conservative
well the office for Budget
responsibilities say yesterday that what
we're doing is actually making the
recession shallower it's saving jobs but
what I would say to my conservative
colleagues is you know there is nothing
conservative about spending money that
you haven't got there is nothing
conservative about not tackling
inflation there's nothing conservative
about ducking difficult decisions that
put the economy on track and we've done
all of those things and that's why this
is a very conservative package to make
sure that we sort out the economy which
is one of the most important things that
people expect from us as a party
but they might say back to you household
incomes Falling by seven percent in the
next 18 months essentially the run-up to
the next general election taxation as a
share of GDP at its highest level since
the war unemployment is going to be
rising house prices are going to be
rising why would you vote conservative
at the next election
and I'm going to have to make this the
last answer I'm afraid because I've got
to do some other interviews but let me
answer that very directly people vote
conservative because they know we will
take the tough and difficult decisions
in the long-term interests of the
country that's what we are doing today
none of this is easy but it's the right
thing to do and if we're going to bring
down the cost of people's shopping bills
make people's jobs more secure look
after the economy then people know
that's what they get with the
conservative party at the same time as
that we're making sure that the NHS has
the support it needs our schools have
the support they need to get them
through a very difficult period and
that's why I think it's a balanced
package that everyone will feel able to
support thank you very much okay Jeremy
Hunt thank you we'll let you go and do
those other interviews thanks very much
indeed
and he's off well the Autumn statement
as you might imagine does dominate at
the front pages of this morning's
newspaper
papers uh hunt paves the way for years
of pain that's the headline on the front
of the financial times
Carnage reads the mirror talking about
the millions set to feel the pain of the
new measures
from bad to worse the Guardians take on
the announcements made by the chancellor
the telegraph rise that Britain's
welfare bill is to rise by almost 90
billion pounds after Jeremy Hunt
protects benefit claimants and
pensioners from soaring inflation
also on the Autumn statement The Daily
Mail says that middle earners and
Strivers were hammered with a stealth
tax squeeze and years of tax paying
ahead is on the front of the times
so plenty more about the Autumn
statement on this show as we continue to
digest it and I'll be speaking a little
bit later to The Economist Richard Davis
with typical energy bills set to rise
from April we'll also get the thoughts
of the chairman of the Energy company
utilita
and then just after eight o'clock I'll
be joined by the shadow Chancellor
Rachel Reeves
[Music]
so plenty coming up but first some
exclusive research by the nuffield Trust
In partnership with Sky News shows that
despite new funding for the NHS the
service is actually worse off research
reveals nearly all of the additional NHS
funding announced by the chancellor
yesterday will be eaten up by inflation
plus it faces the growing demands of an
aging population as well so let's talk
through this a little bit more with our
data and forensics correspondent Tom
Cheshire and Tom interesting actually
that Jeremy Hunt just at the end of the
interview there was talking about this
new money he's putting into the Health
Service despite other budgets going to
be squeezed it's but this research
suggesting that it won't go as far as
hoped yeah because it is a lot of money
it's 3.3 billion over the each year over
the next two years out of a total NHS
budget of around 152 billion so there is
a lot of money going in but this
research by nuffield trust in our
analysis shows that it is going to be
eaten out very quickly we can show you
what that money is going to be spent on
that additional income if you look just
there we can see that actually in the
first year there is uh 0.8 billion of
new funding but the rest of it that is
inflation eating up a huge chunk of 1.7
billion growing demand 0.9 billion we
talk about growing demand that is a
growing population an aging population
and then next year well there's really
no room for improving services that is
all going on Rising prices and growing
demand there's a huge amount going on
here and we can look at what inflation
specifically is doing to those costs
um especially in terms of energy look at
that it's gone up a huge amount of 120
million pounds there and this is only up
to March this is for the year too much
so we haven't had the worst of those
price increases we've spoken to some uh
and one NHS trust who said they expect
it to Triple over the next year so that
is only going to get harder that sort of
pressure so it is not um an easy picture
we know there are seven million people
waiting for treatment uh the chief
executive the NHS providers said that
this is really enough to keep the show
just enough to keep the show on the road
but not enough to improve services and
that's another thing we've seen over the
last years and the last thing we want to
look at today if you think about how
much we invest in the long-term capital
one way of looking at that is in terms
of the infrastructure of the NHS the
buildings the hospitals everything they
have and over the last sort of years
that money hasn't really been spent in
the same way so 4.3 billion pounds
actually uh since 2013 to 2019 that was
earmarked for going into improving
hospitals and that hasn't happened and
as a result we've seen that the cost to
repair NHS buildings has just kept
Rising 5 billion pounds in 2015 that is
now 10.2 billion pounds and if you look
at that red chart that's also got bigger
that is high risk that means uh
buildings there could result in
catastrophic failure so there is a lot
of money going in it hasn't been cut by
any means but that's just going to be
eating up straight away and we're not
likely to see that long-term investment
especially in terms of repairing NHS
buildings that are lost a lot of
hospitals desperately need Tom the
figures are staggering aren't they
thanks very much indeed
Now new figures have shown that more
than 3 000 children were strip searched
by police in a year and more than a
third were black according to a home
office report there were 65
336 stripped searches carried out
by 28 of 43 forces in England and Wales
in the year to March
more than 3 000 were carried out on 10
to 17 year olds and 90 of adults who
were strip searched were black that
figure climbed to 35 amongst those under
18.
in the United States the house Speaker
Nancy Pelosi has announced that she
won't run for re-election as leader of
the Democrats in the House of
Representatives in the new year she'll
step aside after leading the Democrats
since 2003 becoming the first woman
speaker
police 21 people including 10 children
have died in a fire in a building in a
densely populated refugee camp in the
Gaza Strip gaza's interior Ministry said
an initial investigation revealed that
large amounts of petrol had been stored
at the site which fueled The Blaze
what's up
U.S vice president Kamala Harris has
convened a meeting of the leaders of
Japan South Korea Australia New Zealand
and Canada after North Korea tested an
InterContinental intercontinental
ballistic missile overnight well joining
me now is our Asia correspondent Helen
Ann Smith so Helen and tell us a little
bit more about this launch by North
Korea
yeah well the Japanese and the South
Korean authorities have confirmed they
believed that North Korea fired an
intercontinental ballistic missile
that's essentially a missile long-range
enough to theoretically be able to hit
targets accurately on the other side of
the world including for example in the
United States the Japanese believe that
this missile fell into the sea about 130
miles
um off the coast of Japan it's just
worth saying that this is part of a real
barrage a real ramping up of tensions
um on the Korean peninsula there has
been at least 33 missiles fired by the
North Koreans in the first week of
November alone and this calendar year of
2022 has seen the most missiles launched
by North Korea than of any year since
the current leader Kim Jong-un came to
power so a real ramping up of tensions
the North Koreans for their part they
say they are responding to what they see
as provocations President Biden met with
the leaders of Japan and with and the
leaders of South Korea on Sunday day to
discuss their sort of increased
cooperation together in response to
North Korea they see that as very very
provocative and then the Americans and
the South Koreans also undertook joint
military exercises back at the beginning
of November which was a part of the
reason for such big activity by the
North Koreans in response then so this
is this real ramping up of tensions and
as you said Kamala Harris who was
currently in Thailand at the Asia
Pacific economic cooperation meeting
with leaders from across the world she's
convened a side meeting with a
collection of world leaders to discuss
this issue to discuss the joint response
and she's been commenting publicly about
what happened as well today
we strongly condemn these actions and we
again call for North Korea to stop
further unlawful destabilizing Acts on
behalf of the United States I reaffirm
our Ironclad commitment to our
indo-pacific alliances together the
countries represented here will continue
to urge North Korea to commit to serious
and sustained diplomacy
the real concern from the Americans
certainly from the south Koreans and
other interested countries in the region
is if and when North Korea moves forward
to undertake another full nuclear test
if it does that it would be the seventh
time it's done that but the last time
wasn't uh since uh 2017 so really some
years ago and that would be considered
as a real test to the very sort of
unstable and sort of nerve-wracking
truce that currently exists on the
Korean Peninsula the South Koreans in
particular have made noises about the
fact that they would have to be seen to
respond if such a test was undertaken so
that is something that many believe the
North Koreans are working up to and
certainly many in the region feel very
anxious about indeed hello Nan thanks
very much indeed
while also making the news this morning
cop 27 is winding down today but the
negotiations for a final deal are
dragging on reparations for countries
ravaged by climate change and
consequences for those who don't deliver
on climate targets are just some of the
key issues the negotiators are hoping to
pin down on the final day
Egyptian British activist Allah Abdel
fatah has broken his hunger strike after
he collapsed and needed to be revived Mr
El fatah had been on full or partial
hunger strike in an Egyptian jail since
April and stop drinking water on the
opening day of cop27
he's serving a five-year sentence for
disseminating false news
Royal Mail has announced strikes for
Christmas Eve along with six other days
next month the fresh wave of walkouts
that come in addition to the four
planned over the next three weeks
and around at 350 ground handlers at
Heathrow Airport have begun a 72-hour
strike today in a dispute overpay
Heathrow says no flight cancellations
are expected
now the Biden Administration has told a
U.S court that Saudi Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman should be granted
immunity in a civil case involving the
murder of journalist Jamal khashoggi
well let's talk now to our Middle East
correspondent Aleister bunkel so
Alistair how significant a move is this
very significant because it effectively
brings to an end any hope of Jamal
khashoggi's Widow family and supporters
of bringing Justice for his murder and
most specifically bringing the man who
they believe is responsible for Jamal
khashogg's murder or at least for
ordering the murder and that is the
Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia Muhammad
bin Salman it also signifies quite a
sort of an about turn of the Biden
Administration when President Biden
first came into the White House he took
a very cold and uh principled stance
against Saudi Arabia refusing to deal
with the Crown Prince saying that the
Crown Prince was not on his level leader
to leader head of state to head of state
and then earlier this year in July the
U.S president decided to go to Saudi
Arabia as part of a wider meeting of
world leaders but then he fist bumped uh
Muhammad bin Salman whilst in Saudi
Arabia so it looked as though relations
were between America and Saudi Arabia
were softening and then a few weeks
after that Saudi Arabia agreed with OPEC
to cut the rate of oil production which
the American said was effectively siding
with the Russians in the war against
Ukraine so at the heart of this you've
got some two factors you've got the
murder of a Washington Post journalist
in the Saudi consulate in Istanbul a
number of years ago and a family trying
to seek Justice and then you've got the
geopolitics of Saudi Arabia and America
and relations between them at the moment
are not fantastic at all but the White
House say that they had no choice their
hands were tied and that if a head of
state is always immune from prosecution
now as Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia uh
Mohammed bin Salman was not the head of
state but a few days before the White
House had to come to its final decision
he was made prime minister of Saudi
Arabia as well thereby put him in the
head of state role thereby giving him
immunity so that is the legalese if you
like but for the financial mark ashoki
this is an enormous blow okay Alistair
thanks very much indeed
now Catherine Princess of Wales has
visited a Ukrainian Community Center in
Reading to meet families displaced by
the war the princess prays their bravery
as they describe their experiences and
the support that they've received in the
UK whilst there Kate Was Heard
comforting Galena a mother who escaped
with her three-year-old son
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
now Poland's football team have been
escorted by fighter jets as they flew
out for the Qatar World Cup the team's
official Twitter account posted a video
showing two F-16 fighter jets flanking
the country's official state aircraft
until it reached the border with
Slovakia well this display came after
two polish citizens were killed in a
missile strike on Tuesday which is still
currently being investigated
now it's been a pretty Rocky end of the
week for Elon musk's Twitter after the
billionaire gave workers a 24-hour
ultimatum to accept new tougher working
conditions many have reportedly quit
well today the firm announced that
offices will be closed for the weekend
our U.S correspondent mother Kellner has
all the details Twitter seems to be in a
state of disarray there are questions
about what the platform will look like
in the next 24 to 48 hours given what is
such a massive amount of layoffs in such
a short period of time just to recap
barely three weeks ago Elon Musk bought
Twitter for 44 billion dollars he tried
on numerous occasions to extricate
himself from that deal Twitter took him
to court they forced that deal through
and experts say he vastly overpaid for
the company they say in actual fact it
was worth more in the region of 10 to 15
billion dollars he then laid off
3500 staff members and to the remaining
half of his Workforce he issued an
ultimatum over email he said that they
would have to be extremely hardcore and
commit to long working hours if they
wanted to be part of rebuilding what he
called a Twitter 2.0 that deadline has
now passed and it seems that many many
of those employees possibly in their
hundreds have chosen to resign from
Twitter taking with them three months
severance pay which musk said he he was
committed to offering them so clearly a
very very troubling time at Twitter and
in fact Elon Musk has taken away uh the
keys to Twitter he's closed down the
officers until Monday he says clearly
some fears
um that there may be people trying to
sabotage perhaps Twitter so troubling
times for the tech industry as a whole
but Twitter in particular in immediate
peril
Martha Kellner reporting there let's
take a quick check on the weather now
anticipation is rising and so is the
atmosphere are you ready
the weapon sponsored by Qatar Airways
well today looks rather cold and windy
with more rain in the north which may
lead to further local flooding the Met
Office has issued warnings of heavy rain
in the Northeast and Amber warning
covers parts of Eastern Scotland where
150 millimeters six inches is possible
on the Hills
hello you're watching Sky News breakfast
a reminder of our top stories here this
morning a collapse in living standards
higher taxes and cuts to public spending
the chancellor is under Fire for a
budget which spares no one
exclusive analysis from Sky News and the
nuffield trust has shown the NHS will
actually be worse off after Mr Hunt
announced over three billion pounds of
new funding due to inflation and an
aging population
and there's some good news on the
economy UK retail sales rebounded
slightly last month on the back of
growth in all areas except Food Shops
well not a short while ago I spoke to
the chancellor Jeremy Hunt and he
responded to criticism that his economic
plans were against conservative values
what we're doing is actually making the
recession shallower it's saving jobs but
what I would say to my conservative
colleagues is you know there is nothing
conservative about spending money that
you haven't got there is nothing
conservative about not tackling
inflation there's nothing conservative
about ducking difficult decisions that
put the economy on track and we've done
all of those things and that's why this
is a very conservative package
well our political correspondent robal
is here to pick through some of the
things that the chancellor said and he
was responding there to the criticism I
put to him from some Tory MPS who are
quite upset about this Autumn statement
they say it's not very conservative and
it's it's it's not typical of the party
to put up taxes especially in the time
of recession they say yeah this is a
tough sell for Jeremy Hunt to numerous
audiences uh MPS yes also the public as
well because what he's got to do is take
that pretty bleak forecast that Bleak
state of play we had yesterday and
convince people that what he's doing is
not making matters worse and that's what
you've heard him doing in that clip
there saying that the independent
forecasters say it will make the
recession
um shallower and I think part of the
parcel of that as well is saying look a
lot of this if not or most or all of it
is down to Global factors there is
something in that it's not just typical
politician blame shifting a big part of
this is interest rates going up on the
government's debt they have been going
up around the world a large part of this
is Ukraine as well it has to be said
though he's not helped in that mission
by what's happened in government in the
toy party in the last few months and the
implosion of the Liz truss project
because that has made it more important
than ever that they show responsibility
and show respect restraint in what they
are spending there are real points of
tension within this policy package that
cause could cause problems with the
public as well you pointed one out to
Jeremy Hunt which was how is it fair
that on this package anyway it looks
likely that public sector workers won't
get a pay rise that goes anywhere near
Rising prices and yet pensioners will be
getting 10 11 increase up rated in their
in their packets
um next year he said well pensioners
can't work longer hours and work harder
it doesn't tend to usually go down too
well Tory ministers telling people that
if they essentially want to deal with
cost of living they just need to work
harder as far as Tory MPS go there isn't
that much uh sort of vicious backlash
yet it's rather muted we had Ian Duncan
Smith on yesterday saying the jury out I
expect that to grow over the months
ahead though because toy MPS know that
they've got a general election in
probably two years time and leading into
that they will have Rising inflation
they will have living standards going
through the floor mortgages going up
they are I think feeling that that is a
tough sell on the doorstep and that is
why I think the heat will start to turn
up on Jeremy Hunt and Richie sunac if
not now in the months ahead yeah really
interested to see what the reaction is
as the days roll on the moment thanks
very much indeed
so let's get more on this subject and
get the view of Richard Davis he's the
director of the UK's economics
Observatory Think Tank and a former
treasury advisor to former Chancellor
George Osborne he joins us now very good
morning to you and so what did you make
of it
I think the first thing to say
um is that we've gone back to following
the proper process and now that might
seem an odd reaction with everything
that's going on to be concerned about
the process but it really is important
back in 2010 the UK put in place this
system where we have an independent
review of how the country's doing done
by the office of budget responsibility
and that had been ducked by the previous
Chancellor and so what Jeremy hunted is
he went back to the normal process and
asked them look how is the economy doing
and actually took their advice took
their forecast
now that forecast and the reason that
this is such a big story is sort of
unrelentingly bad and he then had to
react to that so the first thing we need
to say is we've gone back to the process
we should have been following but it's a
new reality for the UK and that reality
is zero growth pretty much between 2019
and 2024 so a flatlining economy
essentially well yes so back to the
normal process but nothing normal about
what's being announced um the chancellor
has said is 55 billion pounds worth of
tax Rises and deferred spending carts
were necessary to restore the
government's fiscal credibility do you
think he's managed to do that
I think he has
um uh within the context of this really
difficult challenge that he faced so so
what's he what's he done that's good we
know that the economy is weakening
already and so he had to um make these
savings but he also has a question uh to
answer over the timing of them and what
he's done is he's pushed back as much as
possible the spending cuts to the latter
half of the parliament and actually in
the coming years the in the near term
there's actually some support for
schools and Hospitals now given the rate
of inflation as you reported just before
this segment actually in real terms that
is in inflation adjusted terms uh it
means that even schools and hospitals
that are getting this extra money are
going to be feeling the pinch but the
important thing is that he's not cutting
which reduces uh stimulus to the economy
as the economy is weakening he's trying
to get us through the recession and as
the economy starts to strengthen then
put in place the cuts the flip side of
that is taxes those will come earlier
and much of that will come through the
fact that the economy is going through
inflation so all of us wherever you are
in the in the um income uh distribution
are going to be nudging up towards
higher pay bans and lots of people will
find themselves paying higher rates of
tax because of the pay Rises that
they're they're receiving
well yes and on the fact that he's
delayed the worse of the spending cuts
for another two years down the track you
have said that you feel that makes
economic sense but what does that mean
politically the Tories may not be in
power in two years time so these
spending cuts that are ever going to
happen
that's the big question and that's why I
opened up by saying I think this is a
new I think this is going to go down as
a huge fiscal event and it's a new
fiscal reality for the UK so and people
are talking about austerity 2.0 and so
on even with everything that Jeremy Hunt
is doing at the end of this uh process
Britain does not end up with a large
Surplus we're still still got a small
deficit so and that is because
um of this huge reduction in growth that
we've seen that itself relates in the
fact that the country's productivity
slowed down about 10 years ago and we
haven't managed to get that back so what
I'm saying is I don't think in reality
anybody either hunts critics from within
his own party or from the other side of
the aisle can get past the fact that we
face this really difficult situation and
we need to get productivity and growth
up in our economy
okay well Richard Davis very interesting
to get your take on the Autumn statement
thanks very much indeed for your time
thank you
now in his Autumn statement the
chancellor announced that help with
energy bills would be extended Beyond
April next year however the typical
energy bill is expected to rise from 2
500 pounds to 3 000 pounds a year
so let's get some reaction to that from
the chairman of the Energy company
utilita Derek licorice very good morning
to you thanks for talking to us so help
is going to be extended but it's going
to be less generous essentially what do
you make of the Chancellor's move
well there is some good but there's
quite a bit of bad and there's quite a
bit that's ugly if we if we look at the
The Goods the fact that the energy price
guarantee is going to be extended
through to April 24 is good news the
fact that we're going to see cost of
living payments continue for uh the
those on means tested benefits which
will be about 900 pounds a year 300
pounds for pensioners and 150 pounds for
the disabled that's very good we're
going to see
um the energy bill relief scheme for
businesses and that will continue after
April 23 he spoke about more Renewables
and he spoke about reducing consumption
by 15 so that was all good but looking
at the Bad and the Ugly the fact that
the bills the energy price guarantee
level is going to go up to 3 000 pounds
a year that's going to be bad news for
an awful lot of people because not
everyone will get the additional
benefits that I've mentioned because
they tend to fall through the cracks
so there needs to be a real push to make
sure that people are claiming benefits
that they're entitled to so they can
access the other help that is on offer
um I was concerned that
um the reduction in energy of 15 36 by
2030 and the the funding for that
doesn't actually start until to
2025 so that's that's uh much later and
we should be doing that now
um he spoke about that we need more
renewable energy I agree with that I'm
an Ardent supporter that we need to get
to a low marginal cost system where we
do use and we don't have to burn raw
energy to make electricity but we also
need massive energy storage and we don't
hear people talking about that enough
because we need to move to this system
it's not just about when farms and solar
Farms it's about energy storage as well
so um I I'm I'm very concerned for our
vulnerable customers that they will have
trouble in meeting for them what is
going to be on average another 10 pounds
a week but of course in the winter it
really bites hard and 50 pounds worth of
energy in the winter will last somewhere
between only three and four days and you
will have got through that 50 pounds so
poorest in society well I'm not I'm not
going to be looked after in quite the
way that I'd hoped if they're not on
means tested benefits well just give us
an idea of what situation is now how
hard are your customers finding it to
pay their bills at the moment and how
much worse is that going to get come the
spring I mean how worried are you about
fuel poverty
well we are very anxious about fuel
poverty we're predominantly a prepayment
company we have 800 000 customers on
smart prepayment meters and we know from
the volume of calls that we get that
customers are struggling and I remind
you we're not in the eye of this storm
yet because the consumption of gas at
the moment is significantly reduced we
see something like uh about 30 to 40
percent gas less being used than we
would expect a lot of that is due to the
exceptionally mild weather but when the
weather really gets cold we are very
concerned that we will see far more
distressed customers coming through to
our call center unable to charge their
meters and therefore we will be doing
all that we can do to make sure
customers are getting the benefits that
they are entitled to and that they can
access the additional support that's
available local authorities did get some
additional money to help them but will
it be enough so I'm very anxious about
when cold weather strikes and as yet we
are living in very mild times in terms
of the weather
I'm right in saying that utility was
actually criticized by off-chem recently
wasn't it for a lack of support for
vulnerable customers has that been
addressed and what more can providers
like you do to help people
well dealing with that particular thing
we pioneered a scheme called power-ups
we're able to give customers advance to
kind of buy now pay later and it was
something that we pioneered and and the
rest of the industry followed us in
various ways of trying to do the same
thing and the issue that offgen had with
us was that we wouldn't allow customers
more additional buy now pay later events
if they hadn't paid back the others so
we've put all that right okay lovely I'm
sorry to cut you short we're out of time
don't licorice lovely to talk to you
this morning thanks very much indeed
plenty more on the Autumn statement next
foreign